now it should have been the day that it
was setting out its stall on the
corporation being valued for money
that's trusted and it's accountable
do you think the director General stood
up to scrutiny today
well Tim Davey is
um he's good
in these circumstances in terms of
handling questions from the Press he's
he's a pretty confident performer uh and
that goes right at the back way back to
2012 in fact when he was parachuted in
as
an emergency director General amid the
Jimmy Savile crisis and it was during
that period that he helped steady the
ship and stabilize what was an
incredibly difficult moment for the BBC
uh I remember him being questioned by
MPS In the Heat of that Scandal and they
were generally reasonably impressed by
his performance so yeah he's got he's
got experience of dealing with really
problematic crises uh I think again we
saw we saw reasonably confident display
the BBC had clearly done a lot of work
to establish this timeline
um but as I say the full facts are not
at our fingers and I think it's only
with time that we'll be able to reflect
on how he has handled this situation
what we can say confidently is that he
didn't know about the allegations
against this presenter until last week
and that probably works in his favor
was his legacy meant to be
accountability and if you're looking at
how BBC News is reporting this do you
think that it's trying to make huge
efforts to be more transparent in that
reporting
I think there are a couple of things in
play for the BBC here
um one is one is quite recent so
the BBC gave water wall coverage of the
Philip Schofield issue
it was leading bulletins they were doing
live blogs on it and I think if it does
not
provide coverage that is commensurate
with the Phillips Schofield coverage
then it opens itself up to questions
about holding other broadcasters to
standards that it's not holding itself
to
uh and the second thing is the Jimmy
Savile Scandal and uh you know I think
that lingers long in the memory of uh
BBC employees and BBC journalists and
um they uh they they have a record of
holding their own uh leaders to account
and I think we still see The Echoes of
that in some of the reporting that we're
seeing from the BBC today
um I think the BBC I mean look I was
listening to the BBC Radio coverage and
TV outputs all day yesterday
um there was uh members of the public
commenting on this story and I think
there's a real risk that mistakes could
be made the presenter could be
identified the victim or the young
person involved in this case could be
identified
um so the BBC does Have To Tread
carefully I think going forward
okay let's talk about the Sun what do
you think it means for the sun there
journalistic rigor really being brought
into question over this isn't it what
steps will they have taken do you think
to check that the story that the parents
came to came to them with was true
it's very difficult to say all we have
or certainly all I have is the BBC sorry
the son's own reporting on this
um
there are a few Clues I think in its
reporting
um it has said more than once that the
mother of this individual has signed a
sworn affidavit
um so there is some sort of you know
official testimony
um potentially legal in nature that the
the sun could fall back on
um if uh if there were legal proceedings
the second thing that is made clear is
that the mother has not requested
payment for telling her story uh it's
been at pains to point that out in its
reporting
um so that suggests that there's no
Financial benefits in the individuals
um blowing the whistle on this issue
um but the sun is being much more Coy
about the evidence that it does have or
has seen uh at no point in its reporting
has it said that it has seen bank
records texts or pictures
um it suggests that it may have had
sight of some of the dossier that the
family has handed to the BBC uh over the
weekend
um but uh we don't know the precise
evidence that the sun has and I think
the statement by The Young Person's
lawyer to BBC News uh on Monday
raises serious questions about the sun's
reporting
um and uh that statement to BBC news
said that the young person involved
issued a categorical denial to the sun
before it published its first story on
Friday
the sun did not carry that Denial in its
reporting